a rare sight in st. Peter's Square this  is part of the vatican city's new  athletics team and they are ready to  take on the world the vatican may be the  smallest state on earth but the team has  lofty ambitions with regards to the  olympics the dream we have is to be  carrying the Vatican flag during the  opening ceremony of a games a marathon  run increased and a half marathon loving  none are among the team members for me  when I began running it gave me the  chance to rediscover inner peace to find  a balance to have time for silence the  Vatican competing at the Olympics may  still be a way off but a leap of faith  is all they need